hier le vote aura lieu devant le congrès
ce sera samedi ce week-end et d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire aux militants de
la famille des républicains de ne pas
oublier d'exprimer leur choix
samedi prochain dre présent extrême non
pour des raisons évidentes au période de
pandémie le scrutin sera électronique et
je les appelle vraiment à voter il va
falloir que le quoi qu'il en coûte ce ne
soit pas un mode de vie
donc ça devient quoi qu'il advienne la
situation aujourd'hui elle est quand
même des réalités financières
extrêmement forte nous avons un déficit
budgétaire qui est allée des 120
milliards d'euros exposé nous avons une
dette qui va approcher les 3000 et
milliards d'euros et ont continué à
dépenser nous allons avoir le les
éléments du projet de loi de finances
natra 10e mais d'ores et déjà qu'il ya
plus 11 milliards c'est à dire que nous
ne sommes pas revenus à une trajectoire
vertueuse la dépense publique et en plus
on a abandonné tout ce qui pouvait à
terme générer des recettes sur la
dépense publique mais je vais prendre la
question de la réforme des retraites
chacun sait que c'est un des éléments
majeurs du retour progressif à un
équilibre financier
doit d'y
rentrer dans une campagne électorale où
on dirait le jour